hello
my name's richard tincott and i've been
making videos on youtube now for four
years
the community has grown in an amazing
way
we've not only got youtube channels
we've also got facebook pages and
twitter accounts
on youtube
we can reach you and you can reach us in
ways that were not possible when we
first started
project
how can important do this better we can
get the interaction working on a
personal level we want people to come
and talk to us and also to listen to us
speaking at conferences in europe and
america
we're going to start the first of the
annual conferences in europe next year
may 2013. we want you there
how can you get involved well easy you
can get in touch with us we've got a
website and an email address which i'm
going to link to in the bottom
who you want to talk at the conference
the languages you want us to use
you can even get involved in the other
other aspects the creative aspects of
the conference such as helping us to
design the page the look and feel of the
conference we want your expertise we
want your knowledge we want you to be
with us to help make this success
we look forward to seeing you at the
conference next year come with us and
make it a successful
you